bonjour merci beaucoup de nous
accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure vous êtes élus de l'Oise
rattachée au groupe les républicains on
va parler de votre proposition de loi
tout à l'heure qui vise interdire le
parachutage mais d'abord on l'a vu dans
le journal évidemment la crise du côté
des carburants près de 30 % des stations
de service du pays connaissent des
difficultés la situation est pire dans
votre région des Hauts de France ou plus
de la moitié des stations services sont
concernées Agnès bannière une hachée la
ministre la transition écologique
appelle les Français à la responsabilité
pour éviter le sursaut stockage c'est le
bon message
j'en suis pas convaincu parce que moi
j'ai fait le test moi-même hier et
samedi soir alors j'habite à Beauvais
écouter j'ai fait cinq stations services
les cinq étaient vides alors si les
Français ont manqué de civisme parce que
c'est ce que nous dit le ministre et ben
c'est parce qu'ils veulent travailler
tout simplement alors qu'ils exercent
des fonctions qui les amènent
directement sur la route ou qu'ils aient
besoin d'aller au travail et ils ont
besoin de leur voiture et il y a quand
même eu un problème d'anticipation de la
part du gouvernement qui a peut-être
même pris à la légère cette
problématique d'approvisionnement des
stations on a vu un extrait avec Olivier
Véran je me souviens la semaine dernière
il a refusé le mot pénurie il parlait de
tension temporaire c'est plus qu'une
périnée il y a un vrai problème qu'il
faut régler et les stocks dit
stratégiques un stock ni stratégique que
si on l'utilise
bon visiblement ça n'a pas été le cas il
faut le faire très vite
en tous les cas avant que ça rentre dans
l'ordre il se passera quasiment une
semaine donc oui effectivement on a
perdu beaucoup de temps je pense que le
gouvernement espérer que le problème se
règle de lui-même ça serait que jamais
de soi-même alors effectivement il y a
un conflit entre des syndicats et une ou
deux entreprises c'est vrai le dialogue
social est toujours préférable à la
réquisition mais vous appelez la CGT as
assez c'est les blocages et entamer le
dialogues avec Total total est d'accord
pour dialoguer si les blocs HS bah il
faut que ça vienne
une marche des deux parties l'une vers
l'autre c'est évident mais le dialogue
social est toujours préférable au
blocage et à la prise en otage des
Français qui est insupportable est-ce
que vous demandez des réquisitions comme
l'a fait Bruno Retailleau il y a hier
midi sincèrement j'espère que nous
n'aurons pas à aller jusque là
sincèrement mais si la situation perdure
et il faudra l'envisager
un mot sur un autre sujet c'est la
réforme des retraites les concertations
ont débuté la semaine dernière et hier
dans le Parisien Aujourd'hui en France
Édouard Philippe dit qu'il faut bouger
plus et il reparle d'un report de l'âge
légal de départ à 65 66 ou 67 ans
je pense que la situation démographique
de notre pays tout le monde la connaît
la pyramide des âges il y a un
vieillissement de la population et il
est évident qu'il faudra travailler plus
néanmoins parler d'un âge pivot ou de
départ c'est agité un chiffon rouge et
il me semble qu'il vaut mieux parler de
durée de cotisations qu'il s'agisse de
trimestre ou d'annuité c'est une façon
de d'engager une réforme avec un peu
plus de
sérénités
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
mais également au report de l'âge pour
vous il faut pas secrétaire du report de
l'âge je pense qu'il ne faut pas partir
de ce point là il faut peut-être
l'évoquer mais c'est le meilleur moyen
de crisper les positions notamment des
syndicats
on va parler de votre proposition de là
maintenant puisque vous l'avez déposé il
s'agit d'interdire le parachutage
électoral pour les députés et les
sénateurs vous nous direz comment mais
d'abord on va voir le détail avec Alex
pusard
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Olivier Paco
bonjour Alexandre et Alexandre déposer
une proposition de la pour éviter le
parachute à HD candidats aux élections
d'abord rappelez-nous ce qu'est le
parachutage électoral c'est une vieille
pratique politique on le rappelle un
candidat parachuté est un candidat qui
se présente dans une circonscription
dans laquelle il a peu voire aucune
attache locale alors on va prendre des
exemples notamment lors des dernières
élections législatives et bien l'exemple
qu'on a le plus commenté c'est celui de
Jean-Michel Blanquer l'ancien ministre
de l'éducation nationale qui a été
parachuté dans une circonscription du
Loiret et cela ne lui a pas du tout à
réussir il a essuyer une cinglande
défaite éliminée dès le premier tour
même cas de figure pour Éric Zemmour
après sa candidature à la présidentielle
et bien il se lance dans une
circonscription du Var celle de
Saint-Tropez là où selon les sondages il
avait le plus de chances de gagner mais
ça n'a pas fonctionné appareille il
était éliminé dès le premier tour alors
il a des parachutages qui fonctionnent
notamment lors des dernières élections
celui d'Élisabeth borne a plutôt marché
la première ministre a été dans le
Calvados en Normandie un département où
sa seule attache et bien c'est son
grand-père qui a été maire de la commune
de livaro parachutage réussi également
pour Sandrine Rousseau l'écologie
c'était élu en jouant dans une
circonscription favorable du 13e
arrondissement de Paris et puis c'est
passé aussi pour l'insoumi Manuel
Bompard élu dans une circonscription de
Marseille où il succède à Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui lui aussi avait été
parachuté dans cette circonscription en
2017 alors que prévoit la proposition de
la defaco pour éviter ces paraffûtages
alors une mesure toute simple un
candidat au législatif ou au sénatorial
devrait être électeur de sa
circonscription inscrit sur la liste et
électorale ou alors payer une
contribution directe communale dans
cette circonscription comme par exemple
la taxe foncière Olivier Paco d'abord
une première question si on prend
l'esprit de la Constitution un député il
est élu avant tout pour représenter la
nation et pas un territoire en
particulier donc il y a une
contradiction avec votre texte alors il
y aurait une contradiction
si cette élu l'été sur une liste
nationale à la proportionnelle or les
députés comme les sénateurs sont élus
sur des circonscriptions territoriales
donc alors concrètement un député il est
député de loi de la troisième première
deuxième troisième circonscription de
l'Oise sénateur et sénateurs de l'Ouest
il est pas sénateur français élu nulle
part
à partir de ce moment-là le
parlementaire il est non seulement un
élu national mais qu'on le veuille ou
non il est aussi un élu local c'est
comme ça la mission du parlementaire
c'est effectivement de faire la loi et
de contrôler l'action de l'État mais
c'est aussi et tous les parlementaires
vous le diront parce qu'ils y sont
confrontés tous les jours c'est aussi
d'être l'ambassadeur de son territoire
c'est aussi d'être le porte-parole des
habitants et des électeurs de ce
territoire et pour défendre ce
territoire il faut le connaître
le sénateur de l'Oise peut vous parler
de Gouy les groseilliers ils peuvent
vous parler de Compiègne ils peuvent
vous parler de rouvrez les merles parce
qu'il connaît ce territoire logiquement
et lorsqu'il est saisi des
problématiques économiques sociales qui
sont très différentes au sein de son
propre territoire il est encore plus
efficace ou les
pour les défendre si vous voulez vous
l'avez dit très bien c'est une pratique
ancestrale ça fait partie du folklore de
la République mais c'est peut-être en
cette période où on regrette tout ce que
le lien entre les élus et
les électeurs se soient descendus que la
participation aux élections soit de plus
en plus faible que la défiance envers la
parole publique soit de plus en plus
forte et bien il faut recréer du lien et
il faut ancrer le Parlement le
parlementarisme pardon dans les
territoires vous avez pris des exemples
qui montrent que le parachutage ne
marche pas toujours c'est vrai que les
électeurs sont assez grands pour décider
par eux-mêmes sauf que dans beaucoup de
cas étant donné que les investitures aux
élections sont données par les partis
politiques
et bien les lecteurs entre guillemets il
a pas le choix on lui impose un candidat
d'une étiquette pour laquelle il aurait
voulu voter mais il aurait préféré voter
pour un candidat de son territoire de
cette étiquette c'est bien ça le vrai
problème donc il y a un problème au sein
des parties aussi dans les investitures
donnés par les parties à tout à fait
alors les exemples donnés par Alexandre
poussar le montre bien aujourd'hui ce
sont les parties qui sont les plus
excentrés sur l'échiquier ainsi que le
parti présidentiel qui utilise le plus
la pratique du parachutage mais tout le
monde l'a fait un jour ou l'autre tout
le monde l'a fait un jour ou l'autre
toujours est-il que je terminerai par là
vous avez vu l'an dernier il y avait une
enquête d'opinion qui montrait que moins
d'un électeur sur deux
connaissait ou appréciait ou avait une
opinion favorable de son député c'est
l'inverse pour les mers qui sont des
gens de proximité donc moi ma
proposition de loi elle est elle est de
bon sens elle est de bon sens rendre
l'élu plus efficace parce que plus
proche de son territoire est-ce que le
groupe républicains vous soutient dans
cette proposition de loi est-ce qu'elle
va être du coup débattue prochainement
dans une niche du groupe alors très
concrètement déjà j'ai une trentaine de
cossignataires et j'en ai tous les jours
qui arrivent j'ai sollicité un entretien
avec le président Bruno de Retailleau
pour effectivement que cette proposition
de loi puisse se trouver le chemin d'une
niche parlementaire mais je n'ai pas
encore eu cette entretien avec Bruno
donc pour le moment il y a pas elle est
pas l'ordre du jour elle n'est pas
encore à l'ordre du jour vous souhaitez
qu'elle soit rapidement on imagine pour
vous c'est pas à vous reconnaissez que
c'est pas l'urgence du moment et qui a
d'autres sujets plus prioritaires il y a
certainement des sujets plus
prioritaires néanmoins je me battrai
pour quelle avance puisque vous parlez
de ce lien entre entre élu et
territoires le gouvernement réfléchit
aussi aux problèmes que pose le cumul
des mandats le non cumul des mandats en
l'occurrence mais oui effectivement
depuis le quinquennat de François
Hollande le député maire ou le
sénateur-mère a c'est fini on ne peut
plus être parlementaire et en même temps
diriger une collectivité locale une
commune en département ou une région on
peut en revanche le parlementaires et
être élu d'une collectivité par exemple
être conseillé à un municipal mais en
pratique à certains estiment que ce nom
cumule des mandats crée une déconnexion
entre le parlementaire et le terrain et
durant la campagne présidentielle et
bien Emmanuel Macron a rouvert la voix
au cumul des mandats alors seulement
pour les petites communes et donc du
coup et bien le gouvernement actuel
planche sur cette question on
réécoutéester le ministre en charge des
relations avec le Parlement le gros
avantage que ça avait c'était de
permettre une connexion directe entre
les parlementaires et leurs
responsabilité actuelle dans les
collectivités territoriales bon dans
beaucoup de Parlement il y a en Europe
et dans le monde dans les grandes
démocraties il y a pas de cumul des
mandats mais ce qu'on voit c'est qu'on a
supprimé le cumul des mandats sans
réfléchir à l'organisation des moyens
des parlementaires il y a toujours
autant de parlementaires et avec aussi
peu de moyens donc peut-être que si on
maintient le nom cumul des mandats il
faut réfléchir à peut-être plus de
moyens pour les députés les sénateurs
pour mieux faire leur travail alors
c'était éventuel retour du cumul des
mandats et bien il sera discuté dans le
cadre de la réforme des institutions
souhaitées par Emmanuel Macron mais
avant de dévoiler cette réforme et bien
le président de la République souhaite
mettre autour de la table tous les
partis politiques pour trouver un
consensus Olivier Pacaud sur cette
question quel est votre position est-ce
que vous êtes favorable au retour du
cumul des mandats alors déjà je voudrais
dire que notre gouvernement il prend les
gens pour des imbéciles parce qu'il y a
même pas un an il y a eu une proposition
de loi au Sénat qui a été déposée par
les centrices pour justement évoquer le
cumul des mandats cette proposition elle
a été adoptée au Sénat elle a été
rejetée à la demande du gouvernement
dont Monsieur Riester à l'Assemblée
nationale donc c'est insupportable de
relancer des sujets qu'on a
balayer du revers de la main six mois
auparavant alors le cumul des mandats
effectivement il y a une problématique
entre la réelle connexion des
parlementaires et leur territoire
néanmoins si on a il y a quelques années
interdit le cumulent entre la présidence
d'un exécutif local et la mission
parlementaire c'est parce que dans
beaucoup de cas c'était difficile de
faire les deux faut être honnête alors
il y a une position intermédiaire et
j'avais déposé un amendement qui a été
adopté au moment de cette discussion de
de l'éventuelle cumul des mandats et
bien c'est que on puisse permettre à un
parlementaire non pas d'être un simple
conseil municipal départemental ou
régional non pas d'être de redevenir
président du département de la région ou
maire de la grande ville mais au moins
d'être vice-président c'est une charge
moins importante mais qui permet de
reconnecter beaucoup plus le
parlementaire avec son territoire et qui
permet à son territoire de bénéficier de
du savoir-faire des portes d'entrée que
le parlementaire va pouvoir apporter à
ce territoire et mon amendement avait
été adopté je pense que c'est une
solution intermédiaire qui doit
peut-être
municipale au conseil départemental ça
suffit pas je vous conseiller régional
je suis conseiller départemental
ça me permet d'être connecté ça
honnêtement je laboure le terrain en
long en large en travers d'est en ouest
du sud au nord toutes les semaines
néanmoins lorsqu'il s'agit de mettre en
pratique certaines politiques très
précises très techniques le fait d'avoir
vraiment les mains dans le cambouis et
d'être plus ou moins décisionnaire en
tant que vice-président ou en tant que
mère adjoint d'une grande commune ça
peut être précieux quand même et se
retrouver juste milieu est-ce que cette
mesure concernant le cumul des mandats
elle doit faire partie de la réforme des
institutions qui ont le sait on l'a vu
dans le premier quinquennat va être
difficile à faire passer pour Emmanuel
Macron ça oui peut-être oui moi je n'y
serai pas opposé
vous n'êtes pas pour un texte séparé
pour être plus vite sur cette question
une réforme globalement oui tout à fait
mais vous savez il y a eu un nombre lors
du premier quinquennat de mesure
annoncées de réforme annoncé qui n'ont
pas été faites que voilà moi je suis
plutôt sceptique quant à la capacité et
à la réelle volonté du gouvernement de
faire bouger les choses ça a été entre
2017 et 2022 le gouvernement qui a fait
le moins de réformes on a parlé des
réformes de la des retraites tout à
l'heure et non strictement rien fait
mais vraiment rien c'est le seul
président de la République depuis 40 ans
qui n'a rien fait en matière de retraite
le seul
un dernier mot sur ce sujet des cumules
démontable vous allez interpeller le
gouvernement là-dessus aux questions
d'actualité mercredi alors il y a une
autre cube un autre cumul qu'il faut
évoquer c'est le cumul entre les
ministères et les exécutifs locaux il y
a pas de loi mais il y a une règle qui
existe depuis 25 ans qui veut qu'un
ministre se consacre à sa mission au
combien importante et il y a quelques
fortes têtes capricieuses quelques
privilégiés aujourd'hui qui
effectivement se sont exonérés de la
règle peut-être qu'il y a un problème de
d'autorité en l'occurrence c'est
Sébastien
lecornuy il me semble qu'il y a Sonia
baquet il me semble qu'il y a Olivier
Klein par an puis je pense citer
d'autres voilà donc non il y a un vrai
problème il faut que le gouvernement
soit cohérent
on ne peut pas refuser le cumul de
mandat pour les parlementaires et
l'accepter pour
certains
ce qui est une charge haute pour vous il
doit démissionner de son poste de
conseiller départemental de président du
conseil départemental des armées c'est
un travail colossal on peut pas être
ministre des Armées et président du
conseil départemental de l'Eure
d'ailleurs s'il avait bien fait son
travail je pense que les élections
législatives ce serait un peu mieux
passées dans son département il y a une
poussée du RL dans leur il y a une
razzia
urn dans son département il y a eu un
effondrement
je pense qu'il y a peut-être un petit
lien de cause à effet en tout cas c'est
parlementaire en marche c'est ce qu'il
disait merci Alex merci beaucoup à tout
à l'heure dans le club on va parler d'un
autre sujet on parlera d'Édouard
Philippe
dans 30 minutes on va aller voir
l'actualité maintenant dans votre
département avec Jean-Marc chevaucher
Jean-Marc bonjour rédacteur en chef
adjoint du Courrier Picard et Jean-Marc
les maires de l'Oise étaient réunis ce
samedi pour leur congrès vous y étiez
Olivier Pacaud des mères très inquiets
face à l'Assemblée à flamber des coups
de l'énergie
et bien oui et ils sont très inquiets
mais ça empêche pas d'avoir du chauffage
parce que on a relevé que le chauffage
était poussé dans la salle où les mers
se réunissaient alors le maire de
Bresles la commune qui accueillait nous
dit que c'est un dysfonctionnement de
l'opérateur privé mais enfin ça fait 20
ans que ça dure quand même je pense que
si c'était chez quelqu'un ça se serait
peut-être résolu depuis un petit moment
mais en tout cas il y a un problème plus
sérieusement qui est très prégnant et
Olivier Pacaud doit le savoir avec les
élus des territoires parce que parce
qu'on leur demande de faire des
économies ils veulent bien mais s'ils
font des économies ils vont plus faire
beaucoup d'investissement ils sont face
à un point d'indice des fonctionnaires
qui va augmenter 3 et demi et ils sont
face à des réglementations
sur lesquelles il va falloir aussi à
cause desquels il va falloir aussi
investir donc comment ils vont faire
des économies sûrement mais ils vont pas
faire grand chose d'autre dans leur
commune donc voilà un petit peu ce qu'on
a vu donc monsieur le sénateur vous
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez faire ou
proposer aux élus pour pour en sortir
est-ce que comme Franck Riester pour les
parlementaires il faut demander plus de
moyens
alors le département de l'Oise est un
des départements de France qui a le plus
c'est commune puisqu'on a une enveloppe
dédiée à l'aide aux communes de 50
millions d'euros
donc nous aidons beaucoup nos communes
mais il est évident que cette année 2023
va être très difficile pour les communes
pourquoi parce que l'inflation dont on
parle à peu près à 5 6% pour les ménages
elle est beaucoup plus élevée pour les
collectivités puisque le panier de la
ménagère et le panier de l'élu municipal
c'est pas la même chose il est avant
tout enfin compte constituer le panier
du de l'élu par l'énergie qui a augmenté
énerve énormément mais aussi par le
ticket de la cantine scolaire qui
augmente énormément et donc
effectivement ils sont un petit peu
affolés les élus ils savent qu'ils vont
être aidés par le Département ce qui
demande c'est une hausse de ce qu'on
appelle la DGF la dotation globale de
fonctionnement et le gouvernement promet
une hausse alors cette hausse elle va
être de 320 des millions d'euros ça
paraît énorme comme chiffre mais il faut
ramener ça à la réalité de la DGS du
gouvernement oui alors mais la DGF c'est
26, c'était 26,6 milliards ça va passer
à presque 27 faites le compte 320
millions d'euros sur 27 milliards ça
fait
1,1,2 % d'augmentation alors que
l'inflation que subissent les
collectivités elle est nettement
supérieure ah si elle est à peu près
15%. donc les maires ce sont des gens
qui savent compter
et donc ils vous disent ne nous prenez
pas pour des imbéciles il faut indexer
en fait ce qui fut le cas jadis il faut
indexer la dotation globale de
fonctionnement sur l'inflation réelle
après les collectivités supérieures
c'est-à-dire le département et la région
il doit aussi bénéficier de dotation
indexées et puis tous les élus font des
efforts pour réduire leur consommation
d'énergie lors de ce congrès des maires
chacun a donné ses exemples alors qu'il
s'agisse de passage au LED de fermeture
de l'éclairage la nuit de réduction de
l'éclairage au moment des fêtes de Noël
de baisse de 1 degré du chauffage enfin
il y a énormément de choses qui ont été
faites mais s'il n'y a pas un coup de
pouce de l'État en matière de dotation
ça sera très compliqué effectivement les
investissements baisseront or les
investissements font vivre le tissu
économique local
merci Jean-Marc armault sur votre une
Jean-Marc on était encore très meurtrier
en Picardie
oui puisque on s'est aperçu que cet été
on a eu un peu plus de décès que
d'habitude c'est dû à la fois au covid
et à la canicule le covid je vous le
rappelle qui avait d'ailleurs débuté
dans le Waze en 2020
sur la question des éoliennes Olivier
Pacot le Sénat examinera dans quelques
jours le projet de loi pour accélérer le
développement des énergies renouvelables
est-ce que vous souhaitez l'interdiction
des éoliennes terrestres je ne souhaite
pas l'interdiction je souhaite que les
territoires retrouvent la maîtrise de
leur sol depuis un fameux amendement qui
s'appelle l'amendement Brotte ce sont
les préfets de régions ce sont les juges
administratifs qui peuvent décider qu'un
territoire va se voir imposer
effectivement une ferme éolienne c'est
un déni de démocratie totalement
scandaleux je peux vous donner plusieurs
exemples notamment autour de Guiscard
dans le nord-est du département où les 8
territoires les 8 communes concernés ont
délibéré contre le projet ou les trois
quarts de la population à pétitionner
contre ce projet qui va probablement se
faire
ce que demande le Sénat depuis plusieurs
mois oui bien sûr et donc le rapporteur
Didier mandeli et réfléchi moi j'ai eu
l'occasion comme d'autres d'en discuter
avec lui si la Commission ne le fait pas
moi je porterai un amendement de droit
de veto des mers concernant
l'installation de de ce type de projet
alors ça
écoutez il faut que les élus jouent leur
rôle ils ont été élu pour ça il faut
qu'ils assument ça peut être renforcé
par un référendum local tout à fait mais
un conseil municipal peut décider pour
sa population un dernier mot on va
parler de politique puisqu'il nous reste
encore 3 minutes Xavier Bertrand donc
vous étiez le porte-parole durant la
primaire des républicains a lancé la
semaine dernière son nouveau parti nous
France en pleine campagne pour la
présidence des républicains c'était le
bon moment
effectivement le choix calendaire peut
interroger parce que dans ce ciel un
petit peu troublé que connaît la droite
effectivement cette concomitance
peut-être étonnante le fond des choses
c'était pas le bon calendrier pour vous
c'était peut-être pas le meilleur
calendrier
alors je suis toujours un grand ami de
Xavier Bertrand et je soutiens sa
démarche parce que il incarne le
gaullisme social et il est aujourd'hui
le seul incarné cet esprit à la fois de
solidarité et de responsabilité qui a
une histoire très importante dans notre
paysage politique et qui doit
rester
maintenant effectivement
avec l'élection de la présidence DLR ça
pose problème c'est ce calendrier
peut-être Xavier a-t-il voulu
montrer aux candidats qui fallait
compter sur lui il fallait compter sur
cette famille politique cette sogolisme
social c'est une façon de prendre date
[Musique]
mais c'est peut-être un peu tôt est-ce
que c'est la bonne méthode est-ce qu'il
peut avoir un pied dedans un pied dehors
c'est difficile moi je pense que en
politique la clarté est toujours
meilleure et la clarté c'est
effectivement d'avoir les deux pieds qui
marchent dans le même sens sinon à trop
s'étirer c'est compliqué mais peut-être
que Xavier Bertrand réussira a-t-il à
imprimer une marque de gaulisme social
indispensable à cette famille de droite
qui semblait un petit peu cette évanouie
mais les deux pieds doivent être ou pour
vous est-ce qu'il doit rester dans les
chez les républicains ou est-ce qu'il
doit affirmer dire ben nous France c'est
un parti à part je quitte les
républicains ce qu'il avait fait il y a
quelques années mais peut-être aussi ce
qui lui a coûté la victoire à la
primaire est-ce que là il est en train
de refaire la même erreur peut-être
peut-être je pense franchement que à
partir du moment où il avait quitté les
républicains et revenir ça lui a coûté
effectivement la primaire là il est
resté républicain il crée ce qui était
d'abord un fine tank et qui devient
aujourd'hui un parti donc effectivement
ça trouble certains militants qui me
l'ont dit alors je ne suis plus elle est
je suis resté hors DLR depuis
effectivement 2017 mais je comprends
effectivement la le malaise chez
certains comme je comprends la volonté
de Xavier Bertrand de faire en sorte que
le gaullisme social soit encore présent
parce que si pour aujourd'hui chez les
républicains en tous les cas dans
l'esprit de beaucoup de gens il ne l'est
plus
il ne l'est plus et je l'espère que
Bruno Retailleau notamment ou Aurélien
Pradier seront le faire revivre vous
savez la droite il faut qu'elle marche
sur deux jambes il faut qu'elle marche
sur une jambe effectivement d'ordre
d'identité mais aussi de redistribution
des richesses
si j'avais à voter je voterai pour Bruno
clairement un homme de parole de
conviction c'est un homme aussi qui a un
large panel
au niveau de ses idées et qui à mon avis
pourra mieux représenter cette famille
politique oui merci Olivier Paco merci
d'avoir été notre invité pendant
[Musique]